[Musique]
ça va
comment il va m'en berbères tenues
changer ton corps il était temps barret
freud je suis déterminée j'ai pas
compris africains cima je suis déterminé
frérot je te fait ronfler abdelkader tu
as compris c'est une salle de sport
c'est pas une chicha la baisse à nous
l'a pas de ça ici d'accompli on
recommence whip it
ok monsieur à témoin à l'anp sont en
mode homme c'est bien
oui hakim oui ok mais comment voilà à
produire des pc brésil oui je peux moi
je suis pas prêt à me battre pour te
voir pour ça moi ah non moi je veux bien
passer dans les réseaux ça bon après je
subisse une bagarre pas encore que tu as
tu ne va guère pas et moi si j'avais tôt
car je vais me battre contre des
voitures un contre un maudit moi
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon je t'explique
en fait je me suis fait clasher sur les
réseaux sociaux voilà par un mec il est
connu je tairai son nom mais il a un
carré plongeant des lunettes et les
blancs paul mirabel ouais je t'ai fait
clasher par cameron diaz un peu dégoûté
j'ai compris qu'on avait envie de battre
ouais il faut que je me tape pro-junte a
frappé à la bonne porte je sais j'ai
quelques bases bon on va commencer par
la base des bases
alors tu vas penser à tout ce qui était
désagréable pour toi ton enfance dans
les quartiers populaires les paraboles
aux fenêtres les dit d'ailleurs les becs
qui touche les murs non tu pense à tout
ça d'accord et ont fait quelque chose à
la gamme chercher maintenant oui à qui
mme royal méchant hakim méchant hakim
way où tu t'excuses
qui frappe comme une mauviette week-end
car a dans le bide je peux pas m'excuser
il allé trop loin d'un truc
écoutez king tu vas perdre ta pas les
épaules
c'est pas un jeu là d'ailleurs au talent
unir et pas prêts pour la guerre où tu
repars à tes vidéos et bonjour il ya une
pile qui a fait du scooter machin truc
là la guerre tu oublies d'un gosse
aujourd'hui réservé toi allez je porte
plainte il va porter plainte
mais je sais pas moi qui t'ai dit de
faire ça je paye bukavu moi
j'ai des codes d'honneur merci du
conseil tout cas tu t'en veux
pas de mirabel ssb
hakim
à plus tard ou ya merci frérot pardon je
t'ai déjà dit d'arrêter frérot
[Musique]